Speaker 1: So I have an admission to make
that might strike you as a weird thing for
someone who hosts a show about American politics
to say, I absolutely hate politics, I hate
it.
And what I mean by that is not that I don't
care about the issues that I talk about on
the show.
I care deeply about the issues that I address
on the show.
What I mean is I hate the fact that the reason
the show is the way it is and that elections
are the way they are and that the country
is the way that that it is.
And the political system we have is the one
we have is based on a huge portion of this
country being a combination of ignorant, bad
faith actors and people whose views are completely
retrograde and antithetical, immorally antithetical
to the direction that we as a country and
as a human race should be going.
I hate that this is what politics is in the
United States.
I don't like the fact that when I take phone
calls from the audience, part of what I have
to do, because the alternative is to allow
it to go unchallenged.
I hate that.
Part of what I have to do is talk to people
with just terrible, ignorant, disgusting ideas
rooted in misunderstandings of how the world
works and a backwards morality that I find
to be despicable, to put it, to put it lightly.
I don't want to have people like that in my
life.
It's optional that such people exist.
It doesn't have to be this way.
We could have a more informed and educated
population, but this is what it is.
And I hate the fact that this is what it means
to engage in politics in the United States.
It's dealing with these horrible people and
bad ideas.
I hate that because of these reactionary right
wing movements, when we have a pandemic, we
actually have to fight people just to get
them to accept uncontroversial science.
It's a waste of time, but it has to be done
because it's what we're dealing with.
I hate that when we could be figuring out,
I don't know how to move away from dirty energy
and start treating the planet with some respect
and reorganizing our economies and societies
to be more sustainable, we're still dealing
with people who just don't accept the science.
We're still dealing with people who, you know,
they don't think abortion should be legal
or that two gay people should be able to legally
get married.
It's disgusting.
It's a waste of time.
Look at what we have to deal with because
of how things work in the United States.
And one of the real frustrations of American
politics is that much like some aspects of
consumer culture, we're wasting time thinking
about the wrong things.
What I mean by that is I recently watched
some great interviews with the late author
David Foster Wallace, whose book Infinite
Jest I'm reading now.
And one of the things that struck me about
his sort of critique of consumer culture and
even David Foster Wallace critique of much
of the kind of literary analysis space is
that we spend very little time actually thinking
about are we thinking about the right things?
And when we look at the points of focus for
American politics and media is the reality
that these are the things we focus on because
there are people that are so ignorant and
reactionary that they want to fight us on
them.
You then start to realize how much we're really
missing in our ability to make progress.
And I'll give you some examples here in the
United States, the modern political media
space ends up saying very little about what
are some of the biggest questions of our time
right now?
Are we, as a human race, advanced enough and
wealthy enough to end abject poverty and that
degree of human suffering and make sure everybody
is at least housed and fed?
This is a really fundamental and basic question.
And the answer is obviously, yes, it's a matter
of political will.
We should just be figuring out, hey, you know
what?
We've got the money and we've got the Know-How.
Let's end abject poverty.
Let's end global hunger.
But it becomes completely intractable because
we have to deal with people who immediately
go to socialist this and communist that and
Trumpy and free markets and supply side economics.
I mean, trash, truly trash.
Another question, are we going to figure out
a way to organize ourselves so that we.
And live what I would call sustainably on
this planet, we can do it, it's a matter of
how we do it, not whether we need to.
And we are rapidly advancing in so many technologies
solar, electric vehicles, geothermal, carbon
capture.
But instead of having a society that is doing
really an incredibly patriotic or humanistic
thing and saying we are dealing with this
right now, we're all together furthering this
technology and we're on the same page that
we just have to do this for the sake of the
human race.
We've identified the problem and we're dealing
with it now.
Instead, we're relegated to arguing with people
who won't even accept it's a problem, who
think it makes a scientific point to bring
a snowball inside indoors in Washington, D.C.
in winter.
It's just a total garbage situation.
And so what I mean when I say I seriously
hate politics is that I hate that this is
what we have to deal with when we engage with
the political system.
Now, obviously, to change the system, you
have to engage with it.
If you just ignore the system, bury your head
in the sand, you accomplish nothing other
than letting the people with the worst instincts
make all the decisions.
That's tragic and that's devastating.
And so in order to fix American politics,
we do have to pay attention and we do have
to engage with these retrograde, disgusting,
baseless ideas.
And that's what I mean by hating politics,
because we have to face the reality t